[Musica]
[Applauso]
una pallina rossa una semplice pallina
rossa quando puoi dirci di più
sulle nostre scelte sul nostro cervello
sui nostri piani b e sul nostro
comportamento sul modo in cui prendiamo
le nostre decisioni
quando mi è stato chiesto di salire su
questo palco 11 nei primi oggetti a cui
pensate proprio questa pallina rossa
vorranno il logo dell'evento che formato
appunto da due palline in movimento
questa pallina rossa è uno dei primi
oggetti che è stato utilizzato per
studiare un effetto di maggio da un
punto di vista psicologico
norman triplett psicologo statunitense
agli inizi del secolo scorso
studio proprio questo effetto uno tra i
primi fu un certo senso il pioniere di
quella che noi oggi chiamiamo neuro
magia che cos'è la neuro magia alla
neuro magia
l'incontro tra le neuroscienze le
scienze che studiano il funzionamento
del nostro cervello
la psicologia e l'illusionismo la magia
la precisazione
questo termine è stato coniato da due
neuroscienziati stephen michnick e
susana martinez con della state
university of new york in un articolo di
una rivista scientifica nel 2008 tra
l'altro questi due neuro scienziati sono
marito e moglie pensate quanto possono
essere interessanti i primi appuntamenti
a parlare di aree del cervello che si
attivano e di neurotrasmettitori
bene questi due scienziati noi
abbiamo siamo molto grati perché hanno
riportato in auge gli studi su un tema
così particolare su quello della neuro
magia infatti voi probabilmente vi
starete chiedendo quanti sono gli studi
le ricerche i casi prese in
considerazione in un tema così
affascinante e misterioso allo stesso
tempo
centinaia migliaia decine di migliaia no
meno di cento
questi sono gli studi come potete vedere
sul rapporto tra le neuroscienze
l'illusionismo negli ultimi anni
pochi sicuramente 12 nel secondo scorso
i restanti dal 2000 in poi
pochi ma con un aumento esponenziale e
questo aumento è dovuto principalmente a
due fattori il primo è sicuramente il
progresso tecnologico
pensate a quando secoli fa per osservare
un cervello per studiarlo bisognava per
forza utilizzare quello di una persona
defunta oggi grazie a strumenti sempre
più raffinati come le tecniche di
neuroimaging o la risonanza magnetica
possiamo finalmente vedere un cervello
in attività il secondo è il perché le
neuroscienze abbiano così tanto a cuore
l'illusionismo perché si sono accorti
che molte delle aree che si attivano
quando noi guardiamo un effetto di
mangiare sono le stesse che si attivano
nella nostra vita di tutti i giorni nel
nostro quotidiano e anche in alcuni casi
di cronaca
inoltre come afferma lo stesso mac nick
alcuni degli esperimenti che vengono
condotti sul palco sono quasi più
efficaci di quelli condotti in
laboratorio
ma torniamo a noi che cosa è successo
torniamo la nostra pallina rossa e per
che cosa è successo non intendo cosa è
successo prima durante l'effetto di
magia o meglio non mi riferisco al
trucco al metodo che c'è dietro al gioco
di prestigio vorrei andare molto oltre
per capire che cosa è successo
all'interno del nostro cervello
siete stati vittime di quello che viene
comunemente definito effetto priming un
effetto basato su ripetizioni e
aspettative in particolare i primi due
lanci la ripetizione del primo lancio ha
portato ad un'aspettativa sull'ultimo
lancio ovvero quello di vedere la
pallina a lasciare la mano e ricadere
nel palmo quando questa aspettativa
viene delusa
ecco che ci sentiamo in qualche maniera
destabilizzati vittime di quello che
viene chiamato poi effetto wow che ciò
che ci permette di stupirsi di fronte ad
un effetto di magia
tutti noi ragioniamo per aspettative
perché perché ragionare pensare richiede
attività cerebrale e dispendioso e
nostro cervello cerca delle scorciatoie
in passato questo era utile per
dedicarci magari ha dei compiti legati
alla sopravvivenza che fossero molto più
utili per noi oggi questo c'è meno utile
ma in ogni caso nostro cervello continua
a ragionare in questo modo e continuiamo
a ragionare per aspettative in
particolare nell effetto che avete
appena visto con la pallina sono tre le
principali aree che entrano in gioco in
quello che viene definito appunto
effetto priming la prima è l'area
intraparietale laterale che si occupa di
fare una predizione della traiettoria
della pallina solamente basandosi sui
movimenti della mia mano fanno sarta di
predizione dopo ci sono la corteccia
visiva primaria e un'altra zona chiamata
medio temporale specializzata
nell'elaborazione degli oggetti in
movimento
queste sono le aree principali che
entrano in gioco quando voi vedete la
pallina sparire a mezz'aria
le aspettative che noi abbiamo le
costruiamo con la nostra esperienza la
nostra esperienza ci permette di
costruire le aspettative che noi abbiamo
tutti i giorni questo non vada ad
esempio con i bambini noi sappiamo
perfettamente che i bicchieri stavano
per contenere liquidi e martelli servono
per piantare chiodi i bambini no per
avere conoscenza di un oggetto cosa
fanno
lo prendono lo mettono in bocca per
conoscerlo meglio appunto
ripetizioni e aspettative
e alla base delle ripetizioni bianche
una tra le più grandi scoperte del
novecento
la neuroplasticità una scoperta pensate
che valse il premio nobel per la
medicina nel 2000 aerei ken del
professore della columbia university
ma cos'è la neuroplasticità la
neuroplasticità
una scoperta veramente strabiliante il
nostro cervello può cambiare le nostre
emozioni le nostre esperienze più che le
nostre emozioni possono
modificare il nostro cervello noi
possiamo allenare il nostro cervello e
lo possiamo continuamente migliorare
creando ad esempio nuovi pattern
cerebrali o modificando il volume di
alcune delle aree del nostro cervello
l'esperimento che fece eric hendel fu
con una lumaca non manca di mare del
genere aplysia meno carina di quella che
vedete nell'immagine
cosa fece ken ken del prese questa
lumaca l'ha sottoposta delle
stimolazioni innocue con un getto d'aria
sull'apparato respiratore sul sifone
la lumaca ritraeva questo apparato
bruciando il prezzo dell'energia
con il ripetere con il ripetersi di
questa stimolazione della lumaca si sta
ora un processo di abitudine o meglio di
abituazione che portarono ma che piano
piano smettere di ritrarre questo organo
anche i correlati neuronali divennero
sempre più flebili fino a diventare del
tutto invisibili
questo ci dice veramente tanto su come
si comporta il nostro cervello con la
ripetizione con l'abitudine
questo ci conferma che la mente un
muscolo è un muscolo che può essere
allenato aprire gli studi ad altri
esperimenti molto più complessi alcuni
presero in considerazione pensate dei
tassisti di londra
i tassisti di londra
che si dovettero sostenere un esame
tra i più difficili al mondo chiamato
the knowledge la cui preparazione
richiede pensate quattro anni e mezzo e
la memorizzazione di oltre 20.000 tra
piazze e vie
bene si è notato che proprio
l'apprendimento in questi tassiste
contribuiva a un aumento della materia
grigia nella parte posteriore
dell'ippocampo una zona del nostro
cervello deputata ad alcune funzioni
legate alla memoria e all'orientamento
spaziale altri studi hanno preso in
considerazione meditatori esperti
militari esperti in cui si riscontrava
un ispessimento della corteccia
prefrontale che è legata alla
modulazione dell'attenzione alla
concentrazione in una riduzione
dell'amigdala una zona il nostro
cervello abbastanza piccola forma di
mandorla che però è legata ad alcune
emozioni nella risposta attacco fuga
emozioni quali aggressività ansia e
panico
bene ora vi porterò con me per farvi
vedere come agiscono questi fenomeni
concretamente in alcuni casi particolari
ma anche nella nostra vita di tutti i
giorni new york 4 febbraio 1999
immaginate per un momento di essere uno
dei quattro agenti in servizio con la
sera
uno dei quattro agenti del new york
police department la polizia americana
di new york
bene quella sera
venite contattati vi viene fornito un
identikit
identikit molto preciso e di un presunto
stupratore un identikit
veramente dettagliato con precisi tratti
facciali che ne scrivevo nostra una
persona afroamericana tra il mente molto
giovane di media statura voi ei vostri
colleghi riuscita a rintracciarlo
riusciti a rintracciare un sospettato
che corrisponde precisamente l'identikit
riuscite a trovarlo mentre lui sta
rientrando verso casa sta rincasando
il protocollo in questo caso vuole che
poi intimate identificarsi chiedendo di
alzare le mani in questa maniera ben in
vista
bene dopo questa richiesta ha sospettato
qualcosa di molto particolare alza la
sua mano destra la infila all'interno
della tasca in quel momento avete meno
di un secondo per decidere qual è la
risposta comportamentale più appropriata
siete davanti a una minaccia
oppure no
mentre voi fate questo ragionamento gli
altri vostri colleghi
le altre tre poliziotti in servizio con
la sera esplodono 41 colpi di pistola
uccidendolo sul colpo
questo ragazzo era un ragazzo della
nuova guinea nella nuova abbini al suo
paese d'origine il suo paese di origine
per identificarsi la prassi vuole che
appunto sospettato estragga il
portafoglio e mostri ben visibile i
documenti
diverso ovviamente da quello che viene
negli stati uniti
i poliziotti
entrati in una
decisione avventata in quella che
possiamo definire sindrome dal grilletto
facile un equilibrio sbagliato tra
commissione e falso allarme hanno
trovato in questo gesto un gesto di
minaccia
quella che vi ho appena raccontato una
storia vera è la storia di amadu diallo
morto in queste esatte circostanze
proprio per via anche dell'effetto
priming che sicuramente contribuito in
tutto ciò
questo caso non poche proteste negli
stati uniti dato che poi tutti i
poliziotti furono assolti
e si scoprì che solo tre di questi
quattro spararono dei colpi aumentando
il numero di cui di di colpi sparato per
persona
veniamo ora a noi per capire come
possiamo avere un piano b di fronte a
questi automatismi
come possiamo prendere delle scelte
delle decisioni con maggior
consapevolezza
per fortuna raramente ci troviamo in
casi così estremi come quello di amato
diallo ma quindi come fare
ecco un primo punto potrebbe essere
sicuramente quello di fare attenzione
all'effetto gregge che cos'è l'effetto
greggio e l'effetto gregge e ciò che ci
porta a uniformarci alle opinioni e
comportamenti altrui pensate magari a
quando scartate un ristorante perché ci
sono poche persone al suo interno in
favore di uno con più commensali perché
perché qualcuno l'ha già scelto per voi
in qualche maniera vista offrendo una
garanzia poi magari all'interno di
questo ristorante trovate anche i due
neuroscienziati di prima
è vero primo appuntamento
quindi è la nostra tendenza a basarci
sulle esperienze altrui
il secondo punto sicuramente è quello di
evitare di fare delle scelte
quando è possibile
avventate e quello di evitarlo
sicuramente questo ci può portare a
prevenire delle scelte inopportune che
siano fuori luogo e che siano
decisamente controproducenti non
possiamo scegliere senza essere soggetti
e delle emozioni ma possiamo decidere di
prendere delle scelte quando un'emozione
non è nel suo picco le nostre emozioni
funzionano come delle onde e decidere di
scegliere
quando un'emozione non è nel suo picco
ci può sicuramente aiutare a fare delle
scelte molto più utili amo molto più
consapevoli questo si può ad esempio
allenare con delle pratiche come la
mindfulness che ci porta a una migliore
gestione emotiva
il terzo punto invece è legato alla
fiducia alla fiducia in noi e nel nostro
potere decisionale
in particolare più tempo dedichiamo ad
una decisione meno ci sentiamo fiduciosi
questo perché il rimugino allarmi
nazione dopo un po porta a una minor
fiducia in noi stessi nel nostro potere
di prendere decisioni
qui il mio consiglio anche in questo
caso è quello di impostare magari un
timer anche una data sul calendario
una volta giunti a quella deadline
prendere una decisione e non
cercare altro tempo per
trovare altre alternative quindi parlano
decisione distinto dopo un tempo ben
preciso che noi abbiamo dedicato a
questa scelta
ecco che una pallina rossa una pallina
come questa come qual è il norman
triplett presa in prestito dal mondo
della prestigiazione puoi dirci qualcosa
in più sul nostro funzionamento mentale
su le nostre scelte su alcuni casi di
cronaca sul nostro comportamento
probabilmente è vero come afferma
qualcuno che anche se il cervello umano
fosse così semplice da capire saremmo
così stupidi da non capirlo lo stesso ma
è anche vero che proprio questa pallina
può diventare il simbolo in qualche
maniera i nuovi orizzonti uno spunto per
nuovi studi per nuove ricerche che
possono dirci qualcosa in più sul
funzionamento di questa macchina di cui
tutti i giorni siamo al volante una
macchina estremamente meravigliosa e
complessa come il nostro cervello
[Applauso]